strikes me that that poker would be a
good game to develop the skill of uh
resilience because if you know you're
playing well and then something you know
the cards just don't go your way
it would be easy in that context like in
real life to beat yourself up and kind
of go into a spiral about this but I
guess as a professional poker player you
have to just get over it yes exactly
um and it
took me and I mean it I struggled with
that frankly to the end of my career you
know if I went on a period of not
winning much a downswing as we call it
it it would because I guess I just
always had such high expectations of
myself and especially as my career sort
of started off so spectacularly
it
it just I never some some people are
better than others at not getting bogged
down by the downswings but I it always
got me and that was my weakness frankly
um
but either way it's definitely it still
definitely taught me a lot of resilience
I'm more resilient now than I would have
been without it for sure
what were the some strategies that you
used to sort of somewhat cope with the
dancewings
and probably the most useful one is just
sort of doing the perspective game you
know just to go okay well so the last
three months have been terrible I've
lost this much I've not you know my I'm
slipping down the because this thing
came out which was like a sort of point
system of recent Tournament results
called the global poker index so it was
a way to try and like rank players even
though it was a terrible actual metric
you know who's all it shows is like
who's been playing a lot recently in
caching but if you didn't if you didn't
play much and you'd drop down the
rankings but nonetheless my silly brain
that loves to optimize for rankings as I
mentioned you know since kids looking am
I number one in the exams I was obsessed
with this and I
would yeah so I have a period of three
or four months with no results ah to
start feeling it and so the thing that
would be helpful would just sort of do
you know zoom out okay so the last three
months of but let's look at the
last year okay it wasn't that good okay
but three years ago I won that big one
there and that was like
still above expectation and then prior
to that and prior to that and generally
speaking just there will be a radius of
sort of time that you can go back to
where things are actually clearly on the
positive
so just choose that because it's it's up
to you which perspective you choose
that's that's what you can control you
can't necessarily control what life does
but you can control the the time frame
with which you want to compare it of how
it's going you know where the trend line
you know is it is it doing this overall
over a 10-year period or is it doing
this okay but let's look at 20 years or
whatever
so that's frankly the most useful one
and it's also you know the longer the
time period the more meaningful the data
right especially in poker you know the
bigger the sample size then the more
relevant it is yeah so that that's the
main one
um and then the other thing as well when
you're especially when you're dealing
with any kind of
any kind of sort of decision-making
process process that has luck involved
is
is to
before you even sort of start playing
okay I'll just bring it back to the
poker as the analogy you know
in between playing whether it's cash
games or tournaments in between the
actual action you need to be studying on
developing a good sort of thinking
process when you when you play it so you
know you need to go and do your homework
and what I found helpful was coming up
with sort of
literally like a step-by-step process
that I would follow during hand where
you know which I know in a vacuum is the
optimal way of thinking through a
problem and I'd work with a lot with
like my partner Igor who's much better
player than me and other Pros you know
what's what is their step-by-step
process okay I'm going to try and
emulate this and work out what works for
me and then at the end of a tournament I
don't look back and see you know how
much I want or not I look back and to
see how closely I adhered to that
process that I know is the optimal
process for me
so basically just being process focused
as opposed to results based
um and that's again that's what I that
became the new metric to measure Myself
by and that was a much healthier way of
approaching it and it again built that
resilience and so on now if I was
spending a lot of time not following my
process then technically I should be
annoyed at myself
um but interestingly I never yeah
would never get that annoyed with myself
I would not feel as bad about that as I
would for example if I was just looking
at the results hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great